you play Young Beth on Yellowstone which
is a super popular show yeah how has
being on that series have you noticed it
in real life when you're at like you
know the supermarket that there's a lot
of people that want to talk to you about
the character
yeah I mean I've been on since season
one which is crazy so
definitely been an expert no one
expected it to be this like massive like
hit TV show so it's like cowboys
this cowboy cowboy TV show in Hollywood
you know so it's like very like
unexpected I guess
um I am originally from Texas so
whenever I went back to Texas I've
definitely noticed a lot more people are
like you're young Beth from Yellowstone
or like there's like there's like
Yellowstone merch in like the airports
or like it's it's actually crazy how
much like Yellowstone merch exists um in
Texas but yeah I for sure noticed like a
massive growth how does it work in terms
of because you've been in some episodes
how early on do you know that they're
gonna need you for an episode is it
sometimes really last minute
foreign
yeah I feel like it can be most of the
time it's it's like at least a couple
man months in advance
so like it's like it's like pretty 50
50. like sometimes it's like oh we need
you like next week or like sometimes
it's like we'll need you in two months
for a day you know what I mean
uh I had one other question for you uh I
am really looking forward to a certain
Joaquin Phoenix film that's coming out
in the not so distant future yeah um so
can you talk a little bit about being
part of that film because I I'm very
excited for it yeah um
I mean it's CR it's insane I still don't
I still don't believe that I'm actually
a part of such an amazing movie
um
I mean I don't know I can't really say
much about it but at the the process was
amazing Joaquin is so talented he's like
one of obviously one of my biggest
Inspirations I feel like that's a given
um
and Ari's so creative and I can't wait
for everyone to see it it's insane one
of the things about Joaquin
um and I've spoken to him a number of
times is that he really uh he's a very
he disappears in the role he's told me
that like sometimes when he's on set
like he will just be in it and it like
it's all of a sudden you'll hear like
you know uh lunch and it'll sort of wake
up a little bit and then he submerges
again like he's told me about his
process and it's it's fascinating so
what is it like to work with someone on
set who is really such a gifted actor
and gives so much of his soul to a
performance I think it's honestly like
it's it's very helpful to me and it's
just everyone on set because it is such
a crazy movie with very
sort of weird
um subject so
so it's very it's just helpful to get
everyone sort of in the moment and in
the in the scene and no one feels weird
about anything they have to do because
everything's everyone's just like fully
and everyone was so passionate about
everything they did and it was great
yeah I would imagine that working with
someone like that and that's because
you've worked on a number of things now
it's really helped you as a performer
and you know to not be maybe a
self-conscious on set yeah 100 100 I
feel like I've never done a role like
um
who I portrayed in and Bo's afraid so I
was definitely a little nervous going
into it but then Honestly by the end of
it I was just like totally out there not
self-conscious just doing anything I I
could and it was great